the breakthrough junior challenge is a
video competition in which we invite you
to submit a creative and exciting
explanations of ideas in math and
science last year Ryan Chester won the
first breakthrough junior challenge
prize make a video about science I loved
science and I've made videos my whole
life it was the perfect thing for me to
do I learned a lot by looking at all the
finalists videos Ryan talked about
Einstein's theory of special relativity
and it's complicated and Ryan brings it
to life through physical experiences
that you and I can relate to no one had
ever explained it to me
time-travel is something that sounds
like magic but there's actually a way to
explain it using science by teaching you
really understand a lot more when you
engage in the idea that you're really
excited about you start to understand it
in a deeper way than ever before that
allows you to both internalize and share
with other people it's always better to
know things rather than not to know them
there's no limit to what your video can
be like we want the breakthrough junior
challenge to be a competition that
engages kids from all over the world
last year we got submission from 80
countries and this year we would love
for kids that haven't been previously
engaged in all different parts of the
world to submit their ideas and their
interpretations of things that are
important to math and science it's
pretty exciting you win a 250 thousand
dollar college scholarship which is
crazy that's pretty much covering an
entire four-year college education where
ever you want to go winning that has
been incredible if I could really afford
to go to whatever college I wanted I
also got accepted to Harvard which I
never expected you also win a prize for
your science teacher that's been your
mentor through this process and your
school gets a lab it's brought a lot of
attention to my school and my city the
mayor of North Royalton proclaimed
February 8th Ryan chess
today which was completely unexpected
but awesome I can't guarantee that
you'll have a day named after you we can
really advocate for it but I can promise
you that you'll have a day that you
won't forget visiting us in Silicon
Valley participating in the breakthrough
Prize ceremony the challenge gave
students the chance to become teachers
themselves and make a short film about a
big scientific idea it's really a
merging of people from all different
fields that really believe in the power
of science and math changing the world
and wanting you to be part of that
movement and now the winner of the
breakthrough junior challenge I'm proud
of you Ryan
and honored to be your teacher
Wow it just kind of seems like a dream
looking back on it my life really has
changed since November if you're
thinking of taking part in the
breakthrough junior challenge this year
definitely do it go to breakthrough
junior challenge org to submit your
video Ryan Chester has a day that's
amazing